with its gold color and stunning rings
Saturn is quite a planetary gem Saturn
is the second largest of the eight
planets and it is about ten times as
wide as Earth despite its size saturn is
actually the lightest planet it is
predominantly made at the gases hydrogen
and helium and because of its particular
gaseous composition saturn is the only
planet in the solar system that's less
dense than water if the planet were
placed on an enormous ocean it would be
able to float
Saturn's gaseous makeup also means that
it has no true surface at its center the
planet has a dense core of water ice and
rocky material but it has no actual
landmass instead it's mostly made of
gases liquids and yellow ammonia
crystals that swirl around the planet
creating golden clouds and storms the
largest storm on Saturn is at its North
Pole it's over twice the size of Earth
and shaped in a near-perfect hexagon
each of the six size is believed to be
the result of jet streams which all
encircle a massive hurricane because of
Saturn's inhospitable environment the
planet cannot support life but some of
its moons might Saturn has more than 50
confirmed moons and each varies in size
and terrain Enceladus one of Saturn's
smallest moons is covered in ice and
only about as wide as the state of
Pennsylvania
Titan Saturn's largest moon is nearly as
wide as Canada Titan is also the only
moon in the solar system with clouds and
a dense atmosphere both Titan and
Enceladus have underground oceans that
would make them potentially capable of
sustaining life Saturn's moons may also
play a role in shaping the planets
signature feature its rings Saturn's
ring system is the largest and most
complex in the entire solar system the
rings are made of icy and rocky remnants
from comets asteroids and moons the
particles range in size from being as
small as dust to as big as mountains the
ring system is divided into seven groups
of rings
altogether there are as wide as four and
a half earths but only about two-thirds
of a mile thick how the Rings are able
to stay on track and intact has to do
with Saturn's smallest moons called
shepherding moons these tiny satellites
orbit between the rings and they seem to
use their gravity to shape the ring
material into circular paths Saturn has
fascinated scientists and amateur
astronomers alike for thousands of years
the ancient Greeks and Romans who named
the planet after the god of agriculture
believed it was a star it wasn't until
the 17th century after the telescope was
invented that scientists like Galileo
Galilei Christian Huygens and Giovanni
Cassini could take a much closer look
only then was Saturn's planetary status
discovered and ultimately its many moons
and brilliant rings because of its
planet like moons light weight
composition and dazzling ring system
Saturn continues to mesmerize us to this
day
[Music]